le dormeur du val par arthur rimbaud
c'est un trou de verdure où chante une
rivière
accrochant follement 2 0
les ions d'argent
le soleil de rentrer chez lui
c'est un petit val qui mousse le rayon
mallet que baignant dans le noac'h
rassemblement
il est étendu dans l'herbe sous la nu à
l'osm à m
la lumière plus
les pieds dans les glaïeuls les bords
sourit encore sourire est en forme à la
new wave est ensemble nature personnes
chaudement il a froid
[Musique]
les parfums ne font pas frissonner sonné
nos narines il dort le soleil et la main
sur sa poitrine
tranquille il a
deux trous de trous jean caude aideront
à côté droit au côté droit
[Musique]